eni vous êtes prêts oui on va faire une
interview sans intérêt dans la bouche
par jean garon ne bouge pas on en est
inégal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dès que ma fille est partie il ya quand
même beaucoup moins de bachir est vrai
dit mme whyte a rappelé la meuf là non
ah bon
sa part rappelé non non je comprends pas
d'ailleurs pourquoi pas ce que je vais
pas fidèlement numéro un peut-être
tu cours on a parfois ouais c'était là
la mer ou à la montagne
pas jeter à la mer mais ouais c'était
moyen d'autres trop de chance sur le
trop de sable trop neutre de j'aime pas
ouais
t'as pas fait pas dix balles pour le cas
dit
non je fais rentrer du fioul ouais j'ai
fait rentrer du chemin
j'en ai suffisamment pour le mois de
décembre un moment que pour janvier
normalement on est sur le coup de tête
il ya monsieur cousin qui va passer pour
en déposer ça va
je fais tout le monde en parle la
voiture avait fermé la porte à la
fermeture non justement j'ai mon arme
qui marchent plus je ne suis quand même
pas aller où je me suis foutu au parquet
à moi ça va alors il ya un gardien
agathois sinon ça va moins ça va je fais
tout le monde en parle oui oui ça va
t'as pas vu ma personne non
je la trouve plus ça se passe bien toi
moi ça va tu fais quoi en ce moment tout
le monde en parle mais d'accord
mais tu y croies se trouve toi non pas
trop c'est pas ses parents comme ça il
ya quelque chose qui me dérange dans ce
trip à moi aussi je suis présent par don
n'enterrez pas non
je me suis toujours demandé si tu aimais
des chiens moi je me suis posé la même
question hier
et j'ai glissé sur un truc et puis je me
suis dit que j'aimais pas les chiens ça
va te sécheresse bien moi je suis
toujours dans parle bien sûr que tu en
penses que ça s'organise bien honte et
chemise la tullaye où je vais acheter
celle infligée chemisier médias
chemisier ben je me suis dit que bon il
soit d un petit peu
pour la scène était à l'aise là dedans
ça va je me sens un petit peu crispé tu
vois mais ça ne tient pas chaud ça a pas
trop le pas trop chaud en même temps il
fait chaud ici ouais je connais la
chemise de seine ouais ça se passe bien
je fais tout le monde en parle moi ça
s'organise c'est vrai ça va ça vient
chanter mais inquiets pour longtemps
pour les questions
non mais je sais pas pour les fêtes tu
fais quoi alors pour les fêtes par
exemple noël ouais et je vais
probablement acheté à sa fin
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu